we're going to test the story that
you're coming up with from the story
Engine with the 36 dramatic situations
and Enneagram and various things I'm
wondering should we name this
protagonist
for me that would be premature because
it's so kind of explosively open-ended
at this point
and
one of my favorite
points in the development of a story is
the point where the sky's the limit like
any this this story there's dozens of
possible stories in this
and I want to
kind of like play on the lava like
Superman playing in lava like
just sort of Revel in the
open-ended possibilities rather than
starting to
consolidate and the name at one from one
point of view is like a detail
but I don't want to restrict
any of the apertures in this at this
point because the automaton could be
male it could be female it could be a
deity of a sort
uh you know that lives inside a machine
and presents as one robot but it really
isn't just that
there's so many
wildly open-ended possibilities that I
would prefer to
sort of arrive at that detail a little
bit later fair enough okay so we have
your book here correct yes okay and this
is just the list of the 36 dramatic
situations great
and it's just
it was created in the 1700s by an
Italian playwright named Carlo Gotze it
was endorsed by gertin and Schiller and
on the strength of those endorsements
hung around for 150 years or something
until George polti turned it into a book
in 1916.
and it says that basically
you can describe any story quite
completely with these 36 dramatic
situations like Pursuit disaster falling
prey to Cruelty or Misfortune Revolt
daring Enterprise their elements and you
can describe any story quite completely
from one point of view with the 36
dramatic situations in the same way that
I can describe this table quite
completely from one point of view with
the periodic table of elements so this
table is carbon hydrogen oxygen
magnesium
and so from one point of view you can
describe it quite completely
and
so
let's see what I'm seeing here so
supplication asking or begging for help
is interesting
because
if we have an automaton
and the need to steal something
and a death or a medicine
and there might be treachery involved
so
could the automaton be asking or begging
for help is the automaton being asked
asked or begged for help
it's interesting
and at this point it all just goes into
The Cauldron
which is just like a bunch of bubbling
ideas that we're trying to in which
we're trying to create life in a certain
way
so Deliverance rescuing or being rescued
it seems like that's what this story
would be about in a number of ways
um
you know an attempt at a rescue
it can be a physical Rescue an Emotional
Rescue
but a deep strong need
for something like that then there's
crime pursued by vengeance
has something been done that either is a
crime or can be perceived as a crime
um
for which Vengeance has sought
and
crime pursued by vengeance is very
context sensitive
because someone might take personal
affront to something that is quite
harmless but they see it as a crime
against them and their
all flared up about it where other
people would be like that's nothing
so it's very
per
ception
sensitive of who sees what as a crime
yeah
and there's all varying degrees of crime
but it indicates that something's been
done wrong and something substantial has
to be done about it which fits in
a story with these elements
Vengeance taken for Kindred upon Kindred
it's infighting getting even with your
dad for beating up your mom for your mom
upon your dad
the infighting is interesting it
suggests possibilities and could
certainly be active especially if
there's like a large corporation with
competing interests
and infighting and
opposing
ethics or something like that Pursuit
very much so like in pursuit of
something especially if you're dealing
like with a medicine
or something like that like the need to
cure something but also being pursued by
you know is this robot trying to achieve
something and there's other people
trying to stop that from happening
so Pursuit
could certainly be active in all of this
disaster number six is you know it's
certainly suggests possibilities that
would be inherent in this idea
and disaster can be like you know the
end of the world
all the way down to a bad hair day so
it's varying it's and it's again
perception driven
because you know somebody on Beverly
Hills getting their poodle died the
wrong shade of pink can be like a
world-ending disaster for that person
so
it again is like what is perceived as a
disaster so the robot
might have to prevent a disaster
and if
that robot does that
then one party in that story might
perceive the robot saving everything as
a huge disaster
in the same way that everybody cheers
when World War II ends except Adolf
Hitler for him it's a it's a massive
disaster for everybody else it's like
thank God we finally beat them that kind
of thing falling prey to Cruelty or
misfortune you know if you're like
ordering an AI
to
do something that goes against its
ethics
then it's like why me why am I
how did I end up being put in this
position I hate that I have to
kill somebody or disappear something or
steal something or
you know just falling prey to Cruelty or
Misfortune is pretty self-evident now
Revolt is quite interesting a rebellion
and that could be like
what's going on with the antagonist
it could be the you know the and the
Android the automaton the robot could be
leading a Revolt it can be a secret
Revolt it can be a global Revolt it can
be a boardroom Revolt where there's only
two people involved and that'll
influence the trajectory of the company
you know is this automaton unexpectedly
sort of turning into a Robin Hood or
something
um
and Revolt was absolutely at the core of
Blade Runner where the replicants are
trying to undo their four-year lifespan
daring Enterprise
you know doing something bold and
adventurous goes along with Rebellion if
you're in that kind of context
but
it's interesting in terms of looking at
it
looking at an automaton who is
programmed and probably imbued with a
certain personality and character
to have a situation
Force this robot to sort of violate
their program and become more
adventurous more daring
and they may not learn that until the
end or that may be something they have
to do early on but it's an intriguing
it's an intriguing thing abduction
abduction kidnapping or like
psychologically taking control of
someone
is intriguing and interesting the Enigma
the riddle the mystery you know if this
robot is being told
to accomplish something and yet the
robot suspects the ethics of the person
who gave that command
um then the riddle of like
isn't this wrong or why is part of me
like no it's wrong and part of me knows
I have to do it and doesn't question it
at all
you know so is it like potentially the
formation of a conscience in a robot
that was designed to not have one even
if it's like a
perfect Warrior that like you say kill
that it just kills that but if it begins
to grow a conscience because of the way
it's being tortured by its master or
whatever like you have to violate your
ethics to achieve my goal
then as part of the robots like
absolutely and part of the robot's Psych
I didn't even know I could question that
and I can't let my master know that but
part of my brain is like something's
wrong with this so the Enigma like
what's really going on who's really up
to what
and then
the internal mechanics of the automaton
like
why am I even asking these questions and
I'm the least suited person to sort out
the ethics of this situation because I
was designed without ethics or I was
designed with nothing but ethics part of
me is supposed to think everything
through challenge everything deeply and
try to do the right thing
you can see how it's like wildly
open-ended and I'm just kind of playing
with possibilities
and it's kind of kind of like what will
happen is like which of these jump out
and grab me by the throat the most
that's probably what will
emerge as the elements with which to
form the premise
obtaining is pretty straightforward all
different types of people are trying to
obtain stuff animosity between can
infighting would be natural in this type
of thing rivalry between Kinsmen
competitiveness
murderous adultery possibly because
we're dealing with a death
um
and so death can certainly come with
adultery and that might be something
that's confusing to an Android I don't
know madness madness is quite
interesting
because this type of situation seems to
infer that
somebody's definitely cracked and has
a substantial agenda
that is contrary
to a lot of
normal societal moral values
but is the robot going crazy
um does the robot need to go crazy to
assert
autonomy
um the situation can be Madness
we have fetal imprudence doing something
unwise which can have fatal consequences
but it doesn't have to be literally
fatal the less the less
um literally you take these situations
the more use you can get out of them
so fatal imprudence could be just saying
something to your spouse and you're like
oh I shouldn't have said that now here
she'll be pissed off all day and it's
not like anything ended but it was fatal
for the mood that day so it is all
varying degrees of everything
um
but an automaton that is programmed to
execute
with an extreme degree of capability and
all that
might still
almost intentionally push the wrong
button
and set in Action a set of things that
could be fatal to the antagonist
even if part of the robot is like don't
push the wrong button and the other and
it just does it
where it's like it's kind of fighting
itself so Madness inside the robot
potentially too
and fatal imprudence slaying of a
Kinsmen unrecognized literally that
means like you stab somebody in the dark
and find out later it was your brother
but it can also be like someone
metaphorically feeling slain and
unrecognized like a dad comes home drunk
and his his little girl comes running
out and says hey Daddy and the dad is
you know really out of it and it's like
I don't know leave me alone and the
little girl feels slain and unrecognized
you know I'm his little darling he never
did that to me before I really feel
slain so
there's so much metaphoric
flexibility in that but the idea of like
an automaton
always being treated a certain way by a
master and then the master says
I know you've been programmed to do this
all the time but today you have to do
this
and the robot could be like
what
why did you tell me to do that like
he knows what I've been programmed for
you know I'm an artist I'm a what I'm
you know I'm a top medical researcher
could be anything but
I was designed to save lives and he just
told me to poison somebody
it's like you know I feel slain and
unrecognized so there's possibilities
like that
self-sacrifice for an ideal
the robot could be faced with that
self-sacrifice for Kindred to save
others all sacrificed for a passion
it's interesting you know
it reminds me of data in Star Trek
who was
you know rigorously perfect in logic and
all these things and yet one of his
deepest hungers was to know what it felt
like to be human or to get a joke or
something like that because he was like
that doesn't make any sense why are you
laughing what is laughter you know so
all sacrificed for a passion like data's
hunger to be human could lead him to
sacrifice
some parts of some mission to get a
chance to
experience what it's like to be a human
for an hour or something like that so
this robot if it's really caught in a
really intense dilemma
could make certain key choices that
violate its programming break it out of
certain things open up new possibilities
the necessity of sacrificing loved ones
yeah that could be what the robot is
faced with doing and it can go both ways
does the maker of the robot have to
sacrifice the robot to achieve
his or her and
adultery I don't know crimes of Love
discovery of the dishonor of a loved one
the finding out you've been betrayed
interesting like the robot discovers
that the master has betrayed them or the
master discovering the robot didn't obey
orders obstacles to love is certainly
inherent in there and enemy loved that's
really interesting
because that means not just falling in
love with an enemy which happens but
also respect for an enemy or fascination
with an enemy
uh
and so
if the robot is caught between like the
commands of its master
and the Intriguing aspects of like a
rebel leader who somehow begins
interacting with this automaton and
has a fascinating argument
the robot may find itself
fascinated by this enemy and respecting
the enemy
maybe even growing to love the values
that the enemy brings to the table and
yet knowing full while but that I
shouldn't even be talking to this person
much less incorporating some of their
values into my operating system
ambition
absolutely clearly if there's like a
master of this robot who has vast
Ambitions and maybe a huge corporation
and like if they can cheat this one
thing then you go from being you know a
hundred billion dollar Corporation to a
10 trillion dollar Corporation and
they're willing to
do whatever it takes and the robot could
be caught in the middle of all that
and the robot's Ambitions like we were
talking about data wanting to be human
and one of the things here was um
what was it
it means giving up their dream like that
speed like what kind of dream might a
robot have
um you know and this this robot could
have been to Jupiter 20 times like
seeing the whole solar system like been
on fire on the surface of mercury and
been rebuilt and like all it wants to do
is like curl up with a good book in
front of a fire or lay on the beach like
it's like it once it's done all the the
most incredible stuff it just wants a
simple little cozy moment they talk
about that in tibetan mythology about
how the gods often want to become human
they're sick of being all wise
all-knowing all seeing and they just
want to be immortal and have like a
little house and a white picket fence
and be finite and not know everything
which is kind of where data was coming
from in a certain way and this character
could certainly be doing that
so ambition is
kind of explosively active in a whole
bunch of possible ways conflict with a
god
Works in two key ways that I see right
off the bat like
the automaton is in conflict with its
Commander its boss
and there's conflicting
commands that kind of stuff confusing
commands commands that can't be obeyed
but must be
and I've often thought the
with Robbie the robot
he says you know Robbie's like and he
really can't fire but he can't not fire
and he releases him from the command he
says if I leave him like this he'll melt
down but the model that I work with in
terms of dramatizing a story is you
put your protagonist in a good strong
dilemma
similar to like Jake in Training Day
where he can't let go of this amazing
opportunity to make alonso's Squad his
ambition he can't let go of his ambition
but he can't go down the slippery moral
slope that Alonso is leading him on
because it's more and more criminality
and
risk and danger so he can't let go of
his ambition but he can't let go of his
moral compass
and then that dilemma comes to a
critical juncture when Alonso tries to
have him killed in the bathtub By the
Hillside gang members and once he gets
out of that he makes a decision
about his dilemma which is I'm taking
Alonso down no matter what and his
action is to go in there and try to
arrest him
and so I often thought that
it's almost an interesting analogy if
you could get to that robot that is
short-circuiting and it's like it really
can't send a command in either direction
and
I don't know what the best way to say it
is but kind of override the operating
system and tell the robot you must
decide now
and like it you know is it going to blow
up is it what's it going to do
but it's like when push comes to shove
could you make that short-circuiting
robot
arrive at some kind of decision from
within its programmed architecture that
type of thing
and take some kind of action which fits
which which relates to this story
because we potentially have a robot
that's really melting down between two
unacceptable commands two commands that
cannot neither one can be obeyed
but must be obeyed he can't disobey
orders but he can't harm a human being
and Robbie the robot
so conflict with a God is interesting
the robot is up against its creator its
master and yet
and that is presumably the antagonist
although not necessarily and yet could
this Commander be up against this robot
that is Godlike in its capacity and in
its linkage or hidden linkage to all the
uh capabilities of this
you know massive manufacturing facility
kind of like Hal or something like that
where there's uh
tremendous capability
so going up against this robot
can be risky and you're up against sort
of all the
the Fail-Safe mechanisms mechanisms that
you built into the robot as you try and
outwit it or defeat it or overpower it
erroneous judgment making a bad choice
the robot could make a bad choice the
master there could be key wrong choices
remorse the robot could grow to have
remorse which it didn't used to have the
boss could have absolutely no remorse
the recovery of a lost one
you know gaining something back that's
been lost
um or attempting to gain a person that's
been lost even bring someone back from
the dead
um
you know if
if there's a key death in this story and
we saw that in
uh iRobot with Will Smith
that the
character played by James Cromwell was
killed at the beginning of the story
and yet the Will Smith characters
interacting with a hologram
of the James Cromwell character who's
trying to give him Clues but it was all
pre-recorded before James cromwell's
death so he keeps saying
if you want an answer to that you asked
to ask the right question
so it was all in there but he couldn't
access it until he figured out what the
right question was if someone died like
say the boss who's trying to make the
robot do a certain thing
maybe is the son of the person that
actually built the robot and the father
recently died and now this the sun sort
of
inherits command of the robot's
operating system and is doing things
that are counter
counter to what the father would have
done
and yet still fit within that Groove so
the robot still believes it has to obey
but it's like going I I don't like this
and so if
the father's
elements of the father's mind or
something were
computerized or
emulated by computers they did this with
expert systems a classic example was
Campbell's Soup where the guy who'd been
in charge of
making the big Vats of soup for 30 years
was getting ready to retire and they
they created an expert system in which
he downloaded all his knowledge and all
the variables like if it tastes too
salty
you know you put in cornstarch or
whatever like a certain amount
and they basically just debriefed
everything he knew so that a machine
could emulate much of his knowledge and
and some of his instincts
so that if some aspect of the master
had been
and possibly even secretly because the
the old man knew that his son might go
this way so that he may have been laying
preparation so
um
the possibility that the robot is
secretly trying to like bring
the original founder back to life to
some degree for guidance or to
countermand the order or to even
regenerate the person physically like
make a clone of them and then download a
mind into them
you know these are all just
Dynamic possibilities to play with and
you can see how as I'm going through the
36 I'm trying each one on like in
varying ways and different possibilities
um so recovery of a lost one that's
where that came from and then loss of
loved ones you know like maybe the robot
brings the old man back
for a while and that really helps the
robot kind of
become more human
and have more free will like the like
the original Master might say you can do
anything you want
like we programmed all this stuff into
you but
you still have tremendous latitude and
maybe I can even go in and undo some of
those deep commands like you can never
disobey
maybe that maybe the founder serves a
function at a key moment
and then
you know like even if there's like a
physical person in front of him who is
the the man maybe he only lives for 20
minutes so there's still loss of loved
ones
but it's enough to kind of like
free the automaton from
the perceived limits that were binding
the automaton
it's the the the classic example that
psychiatrists use a lot is
um elephants when they're young like a
circus elephant
to be restrained is hooked up to a
really strong chain that you could tow a
truck with and into a really big stake
in the ground and it knows it can't get
away I mean it tries but as it grows up
it gets so used to being chained that
they just put a little two by two in the
ground with a piece of clothesline and
the robot still is like up that's as far
as I can go
when the did I say robot I meant
elephant the adult elephant could you
know could shred that but their
they're trained to that and that could
be something similar to the robot and
where the original founder might say
look
you you've Incorporated all these habits
into your daily life and you're like the
adult elephant that's still restrained
by a piece of clothesline
you know you you are a creature of
tremendous power
and
you're capable of anything
and don't
think small don't let your program which
is perfect metaphor for people in the
real world having tremendous capability
but believing that they're small and
worthless and easily controlled and all
that
so that's an interesting element
and that was just you know from just
going through this one complete spectrum
of ideas that can trigger possibilities
um
and we were you know
looking at each one of those situations
kind of through the lens of all of these
combined in varying degrees
and I really like the um
and see what it is is that some of those
stuck I said some of them will jump out
and grab me by the throat like I really
like the sun and the father and possibly
the father killed the son
and the father had more morals than the
Sun and the son is going to take a
corporation worth 200 billion and make
it worth 20 20 trillion like within
three months but he needs the robot
you know to withhold a medicine
or create a disease create a contagion
that the medicine is a cure for and you
know a billion people die and then they
come up with the Cure and then eight
billion people each spent a hundred
dollars on and all of a sudden this
corporation's worth 8 trillion like
literally overnight on its way to being
worth 80 trillion a year from now
but who has to die for that progress and
can the robot
deal with
the ethics and
make a right choice when it's supposed
to just be a robot that just you know
keeps putting the hubcap on the new car
without anything else
so an automaton who is a perceived as a
servant and a puppet and a machine like
you push the button and it puts the
hubcap on
CE to steal
or wants to stop the theft of both of
them are interesting because they they
infer two opposite commands potentially
like protect or destroy or
the the founder wants the theft to be
stopped and the new one wants it to
steal or probably more interesting is
that
the AI of the founder
is recommending to the robot that it's
steel to prevent the Sun from
consolidating this new
um
foreign
and a medicine
going hand in hand with a contagion is
interesting in terms of
um
manipulating a global
uh
you know a global um con
a death is interesting
because we were talking about how the
founder died and was maybe murdered
even a hospital is interesting because
if this is similar perhaps to the Tyrell
Corporation
then
a lot of a per a healthy percentage of
the setting could take place in a
hospital-like corporate manufacturing
facility
and all this kind of subterranean
access
almost hidden tunnels or
underworld aspects that the robot might
be able to
incorporate the innocent will suffer
yeah if it's going to take a billion
people to die of this contagion to sell
eight trillion dollars worth of this
medicine that they've had for years
then that's uh
that's something the robot has to
wrestle with
but it means giving up their dream
well if this robot is designed to be
extremely helpful to humanity
kind of altruistic and
yet has been counter programmed to cause
great harm or allow great harm to happen
and yet is stuck in the middle trying to
resolve that dilemma
that could certainly like the robot
might be programmed to be so altruistic
that its dream is to have everyone
healthy happy
doing well
and it's kind of simplistic but it's
like starting somewhere within the
context of the story we're playing with
here
uh
like the robot's natural inclination to
altruism is being contravened or
corrupted
by the Sun
but what's on the opposite side of that
like obviously the sun cares if they're
worth 8 trillion tomorrow but what does
that give the robot
it certainly opens up the possibility
for
solving a whole lot more stuff but the
sun doesn't seem to have that natural
inclination to use this 8 trillion to
solve world hunger almost the opposite
so that's an interesting
means giving up their dream
and it certainly could be you know that
the robot dreams of being human
dreams of being retired at the end of
its
sort of indentured servitude and get to
live like a person for a while or
something that may have been something
that was always promised to it or
something and then
treachery
glorious
obviously the sun could be treacherous
but the robot could
be treacherous in what it does to outwit
the Sun
and the father could
promote that treachery like you've got
to think
around the evil of my son
because if you don't he's going to beat
you you've got to fight dirty to beat
him because all he does is fight dirty
so
I feel like I've got more of a handle on
a potential story there
I don't feel like I have a premise yet
but I feel like we've kind of cobbled
together something that's interesting
and dynamic and has
high stakes and
complexity and a dilemma of magnitude
for this automaton
an interesting Ally in the form of the
old man a potential strong villain in
the form of the Sun
um so that's a good
we've kind of gotten to a platform here
where we've got something that feels
much more solid than just a
open-ended set of
possibilities
we've kind of cooked it down a little
bit and have more of a something there